with Destiny 2 The Witch Queen in its
assorted seasons in the rear view mirror
2023's lightfall expansion has some big
shoes to fill improved storytelling new
gameplay modes and the ensuing seasonal
content made the witch Queen expansion a
standout experience and lightfall
doesn't manage to reach the high bar
it's set Destiny 2's latest add-on
introduces major gameplay tweaks an
exciting new subclass to play around
with and plenty of fresh exotic Gear For
Your Arsenal but this is overshadowed by
a disappointing campaign and a lifeless
neptunian destination that make for an
underwhelming combination
thank you
lightfall doesn't waste any time setting
the stage taking place shortly after the
devastating events of season of the
serif after a quick slideshow narrated
by the silky smooth voice of Lance
reddick's Commander Zavala which brings
everyone up to speed it is all hands on
deck as the witness finally makes its
long-awaited arrival and the solar
system to battle The Traveler from the
opening Mission the action unfolds at a
Breakneck Pace as a new Shadow Legion of
cabal led by a reborn kallus set a
course for Neptune and you're hitching a
ride alongside them in an effort to
prevent a doomsday scenario from
occurring Bungie has spoken several
times about adopting an 80s action movie
Vibe for lightful and that influence is
felt everywhere on Neptune's primary
location neomuna from a city bathed in
neon lights in a training montage as you
master your new powers to the
introduction of a cast of characters
that include analogs of loose canon
space cops Maverick rookies and grizzled
Veterans just one week away from
retirement lightful wears its not so
subtle Inspirations proudly however at
the same time the campaign has the depth
of a direct to VHS action flick the
story is frustratingly vague as you
chased down a parrot causal McGuffin and
counters slightly upgraded space rhinos
and grappled with emotional moments that
feel hollow and unearned lightfall has
an exhilarating start but by the time
you've experienced all eight of its
campaign missions it feels more like the
unsatisfying storytelling of vanilla
Destiny than a memorable 80s action
picture after nine years of being
promised answers and chasing every lead
imaginable lightful essentially passes
the buck to the rest of this year's
seasonal content and 2024 is the final
shape much of the story is focused on
the veil an object of immense power that
you chase throughout the campaign and is
said to be the most important artifact
in the universe however the reasons for
this are not explained kallus who has
become the newest disciple of the
witness is as grandiose as ever and now
resembles say Pacific Rim Kaiju decked
out and armored kitchen appliances
despite all of this ultimately he's
nothing more than a hedonistic bullet
sponge Who falls far below the witch
Queen salvathune the gold standard for
great villains in Bungie sci-fi sandbox
after being built up as Destiny 2's next
major threat throughout season of The
Haunted kallus is unfortunately treated
like an Expendable henchman serving the
witness instead of the grandiose
conqueror that fans had come to know
love and loathe over the years
legendary mode which dials up the
challenge considerably is a recipe for
sweaty palms and victories that feel
hard earned as you overcome seemingly
impossible odds the new gameplay tweaks
and mechanics introduced in lightfall
pair well with the legendary Campaign
which have several exhilarating moments
that can easily slot into a highlight
reel from a dramatic Escape through
kallus Flagship to taking part in a
cabal civil war that throws everything
in the cosmic kitchen sink at you life
Falls campaign is mechanically a fun
Gauntlet to charge through as you master
strand even if the narrative drops the
ball frequently your new Darkness
subclass strand is introduced without
much fanfare frequently appearing in the
campaign as a major source of power
that's barely elaborated on while 2020
is beyond light expansion made unlocking
the stasis subclass aggravating the
manner in which the first Darkness
subclass was introduced at least felt
like a meaningful moment for Destiny 2.
but in lightfall strand hits the scene
after you poke around a random
interdimensional Wormhole and it's
barely elaborated on and is primarily a
set of reality unraveling training
wheels at your given control of
periodically throughout the campaign
until you unlock it full afterwards at
least the quest surrounding lightfall's
campaign do a better job of fleshing out
the expansion and providing solid
reasons for you to go pick a fight with
time traveling murder machines Destiny
veterans will be used to this grind but
between New Missions to claim the latest
Exotics and the weekly season of defiant
storyline which is technically not part
of lightfall itself the story told here
is far more gripping and cohesive
nyamuna the new Patrol Zone where you'll
Master the art of strand is a beautiful
but desolate location to explore thanks
to the populace being conveniently
placed in the Cry of sleep and their
minds uploaded into new Munoz Cloud
servers The Secret City that survived
Humanity's first golden age cataclysm is
pretty to look at but has a desolate
theme to its design despite it being
positioned as an extravagant Metropolis
built by Humanity's Golden Age explorers
it is a location that lacks the magic
that made sabatin's Throne world or
Beyond lights Europa such standout
locations it does have all the usual
trappings of a destiny location from
Lost sectors to the new terminal
overload public activity but its neon
lit facade can't hide a lifeless design
that is mostly populated by familiar
public events and patrols that rarely
deviate from the established formula
that Destiny 2 has been using since
2017. put simply neomuna just doesn't
have the X Factor needed to make it an
engaging location to explore thankfully
however the actual structure of
lightfall's missions make good use of
the city to provide intense missions
that'll have you on the edge of your
seat as for using strand this new
Darkness subclass succeeds in shaking up
the destiny sandbox with its unique set
of powers for each Guardian class Titan
Berserkers run through enemies with
friends and Claws warlock brood Weavers
unleash a small army of threadlings to
do their lethal bidding and Hunter
threadrunners combine elegant silk
strike attacks with graceful agility
like stasis and the reworked light 3.0
subclasses strand also benefits from a
system of aspects and fragments that are
gradually unlocked after you finish the
main campaign so far there have been
some tantalizing builds to experiment
with and combined with the right exotic
seasonal artifact mods and armor mods
strand positions itself as an incredibly
powerful tool for destroying cannon
fodder enemies and weakening larger foes
with my main warlock I've set loose
armies of threadlings while wiping out
entire mobs of foes in one Almighty
blast using strands to spend and sever
debuffs to stay alive and shrug off
enemy fire the key appeal of this new
subclass is its grapple feature an
ability that replaces your grenade with
the option to latch onto mystical anchor
points no matter where you are and swing
into action if you're prepared to
sacrifice one of your key explosive
Powers The Strand grapple is a fun
addition to Destiny 2 that has plenty of
utility allowing you to Grapple straight
into enemies before you unleash a
special melee attack or if you're
feeling brave enough hitch a ride on a
Titan using their Thunder crash super
right before they eat the enemies in
front of them into Oblivion opposing
Guardians are the tormentors deadly
adversaries who shake up the flow of
combat with their unrelenting might and
ability to steal your powers if they get
too close
foreign
ERS have a response to every attack that
you throw at them and learning how to
cut them down to size is a refreshing
challenge to take on Destiny 2's core
gameplay still feels as polished as ever
and in typical bungee tradition what a
major expansion arrives hundreds of
quality of life changes have further
refined the moment-to-moment Gunplay the
developer has been releasing exhaustive
breakdowns on these changes which range
from granular tweaks and the
introduction of new systems designed to
bring new players to the worlds of
Destiny 2 to a completely overhauled
build crafting system and the highly
requested inclusion of character
loadouts for Long Time Players the armor
mod system is one of the most drastic
changes to player investment gone are
the days of transmitting into 801's
Workshop to see if she has that one mod
that you've been looking for as Bungie
has introduced a new suite of mods that
can work on their respective armor
pieces regardless of type Affinity this
is Bungie pressing the reset key on
loadouts built up over years of previous
expansions and Seasons creating an even
playing field for players of all skill
levels to experiment with as they create
their perfect Guardian build the armor
mods mechanic has also adopted a few
ideas from the transmox system creating
a more intuitive menu for you to slot
mods in and quickly preview your build
before you commit to it jettisoning
clunky menus and making good use of a
revamped seasonal artifact means you can
get into fighting shape much more
quickly that Simplicity makes Destiny 2
more inviting and with the option to
save and switch between several loadouts
instantly lightfo's gameplay
enhancements create an exciting
foundation for Bungie to build upon
through this year's seasonal content
Guardian ranks are another positive step
forward creating a defined Journey
forward for seasoned players and
kindergartens alike this replacement for
the triumphs page essentially gives you
an optional more linear path forward to
experience everything that Destiny 2 has
to offer ranging from campaigns to
establish PVE activities Gambit and PVP
veteran players will automatically get a
high ranking on the system and working
your way up to the truly impressive
Guardian rank of 11 requires not only
skill in every facet of the game but
recognition of your contributions toward
making the experience better for other
players as well Destiny 2's lightfall
expansion does not make it good first
impression but beneath a threadbare
story that relies on an exasperatingly
fuzzy motivation for your guardian it
still feels mechanically satisfying to
dive into comparing it to the standard
of Excellence that 2022's the witch
Queen Saga established only exposes the
numerous shortcomings of lightfall and
that's a shadow that the next year of
seasonal content will need to step out
of if Bungie wants to develop the
expansion into something more than a
middle of Road entry that stumbles
toward a final showdown that has been a
decade in the making
foreign
[Music]